My toddlers love eating smores,
but they hate how dirty their hands get,
so today
I decided to surprise them with some Smore inspired marshmallows.
Got started by making my Graham crackers
by combining some whole wheat flour
with some butter, brown sugar,
and a couple of other things
before mixing together all my wet ingredients,
which were some milk and some honey.
I combined that, gave that a really good mix,
and once it came together,
I refrigerated it for about an hour and a half.
Decided to go with a crumble instead.
I crumbled up my dough, popped that in the oven to bake until crispy,
and then pulled it out to cool.
In the meantime, I got started on making my marshmallow.
I let my beef gelatin bloom and then heated up some water and honey,
slowly poured that into my stand mixer while whipping,
and once it came together and turned into marshmallow fluff,
I lightly dusted my baking tray with some aero root powder
and transferred all of that marshmallow fluff over
before pressing it down. Obviously,
s'mores need chocolate, so I also melted down some chocolate,
combined that with my marshmallow,
and sprinkled over my Graham crackers.
Once that looked perfect to me,
I let that set for about six hours,
and in the meantime, I obviously had to eat all the marshmallow fluff.
Once it was set,
I cut it into bigger squares and everyone was obsessed with these.